good morning you'll have
to give us some leeway while we get
together
okay
right this is a hearing on Amendment
92h which is a replace all Amendment and
it thank you madam chair I will be brief
0902 um and this uh is an amendment
replace all for House Bill
1521 and uh this bill will make uh
changes to the definition of recovery
house and specifies how a Recovery House
ought to be treated when interpreting
zoning
ordinances um I have people here behind
me that will uh speak to this amendment
um I'm just introduc introducing this on
behalf of representative groa who is
unable to be here today and I will also
note that um there was an email sent out
by the State Fire Marshall who is in
support of the changes
all right thank you very much turn it
Frost morning Madam chair and committee
members my name is Ben Frost I'm the
deputy executive director and chief
legal officer at New Hampshire Housing
and I'm here to express New Hampshire
housing's strong support for this
amendment uh that is 20
02h um and I I asked um to go first
really to set the stage for how we got
to where we are today um this is doing a
non- gerine Amendment like this is uh
although not unprecedented is a little
bit unusual um in the summertime last
year uh we at New Hampshire housing
convened a group of stakeholders upon
request of some of those stakeholders
to uh discuss issues related to the in
particular the local permitting of uh
recovery
residences and what we learned from
those stakeholders was that um people
seeking to establish recovery residences
uh to help people who are well
recovering from addiction from substance
use
disorder uh we're having a very
difficult time uh because because of
some ambiguities in the law uh some lack
of clarity in the law uh and uh also
because of U hostility to the the notion
of recovery residences uh
generally uh so we sought to work on
things that would clarify the law and
also provide a path for permitting of uh
these types of of uses of
property so the bill really is divided
into two sections uh the first section
uh section one uh addresses the current
definition of recovery house which is in
the fire code RSA
153 uh these uh changes are intended to
align uh the statutory definition with
changes that are also currently pending
in the fire code and also in the
building code which is uh in RSA
155a
uh so working with uh the Fire Marshall
and with um a representative of the
building officials Association and
others were able to come up with with
this language which fits those two codes
uh but also provides Clarity in the
statute uh so for example the the change
on line eight uh something that is
changing the word residence to primarily
non-transient dwelling or dwelling unit
that is language that is consistent with
both the fire code and with the the
building
code um removing in online on online a
safe and safe healthy family like
because of the subjectivity of that
language um living as a single household
on line 10 is shows the intention of
really how recovery
residences work that they are and this
is one of the reasons why the the the
Fire Marshall uh is supportive of this
this change and he's not here he's on
vacation he has sent us a letter saying
so yes I I saw that as well thank you
madam Sher um but what he said to to us
was um the people who live in recovery
houses are all looking after one another
as a family would um so that's the
notion of living as a single
household um the language on line 11 is
not changed uh and this is intended to
mirror what is in federal law uh with
the um uh and samsa leg samsa regulation
that says centered on peer support and a
connection to services that promote
long-term recovery so that is to be
consistent remain consistent with
federal law and then finally uh on line
12 in this change of the definition um
boarding house or rooming house that is
these are
are not uh uh to be uh this definition
does not cover those situations where
you have something that is operating as
a boarding house or rooming
house so those are the changes to the
current statutory definition section two
of the bill uh deals with the local
permitting uh by planning boards and
zoning boards of adjustment which has uh
been a great source of difficulty for um
uh people seeking to establish recovery
residences and what this does is it
provides uh clear direction to
municipalities to planning boards and to
zoning boards that uh recovery
residences are to be treated as
residential uses so if it's in a one
family house then you treat it you do
the permitting as if it were a one
family house because that's what it is
if it's a duplex you treat it like a
duplex if it's a multif family house you
treat it like a multif family house uh
not as something that is separate and
distinct and different um and in fact on
lines 20 and 21 you see the use of an
existing multif family structure as a
recovery house under this paragraph
shall not require site plan review if it
were new then it would because
multifam uh structures do require site
plan review uh by planning boards um so
but if it's an existing multi family
then it's just the perpetuation of that
multif family multif family use so um
these are the changes that got proposed
but because of the time it took for us
to work through this uh it was many
months of work we missed the filing
deadline uh and we're seeking a vehicle
to get this introduced as a non- gerain
Amendment and that is why we are here
today and we thank you for that I'd be
happy to take questions but I'll note
that there are a lot of people behind me
who with far greater expertise in the
actual establishment and operation of
recovery residences than I my I've
exhausted my knowledge on the subject
here thank you I have one question how
involved we offered to help that that's
a great question uh we don't have a we
don't have a dog in this fight um or a
stake in this game it's just something
we we have expertise in dealing with
planning and zoning and in drafting of
statutes so uh we offered to provide
assistance I see thank you very much are
there any
questions seeing none thank you Mr
right looks like you are all in favor so
I will trust you will not be too
canazaro I don't have a copy of whatever
amendment hi good morning get you
one I was hoping I didn't go first um
your hopes have been fulfilled that's
hope it goes better than this I just
want to thank you for letting me share
my experience with this my name is Sean
um sorry I always get emotional because
this is a touchy subject I my girlfriend
Melissa and I own and operate three
recovery houses in Claymont uh hope to
Freedom recovery homes and I want to
stress that the city of
clamont I'm very grateful for they
worked with us they helped us they
taught us they guided us along with you
know NH core which the executive
director Kim is behind me uh we've had a
lot of help and a lot of
support with zoning planning and all
this stuff I had to learn as I went cuz
I didn't know my goal was to just open a
recovery house and help people like
me that's why I get emotional I always
cry and you
know so I ended up in clamont with a
multif family and I started with four as
we call them beds so I was able to help
four people and it was it was three
Apartments I lived in one there was four
four beds in one apartment and I had
regular tenants in in another apartment
but when those tenants left I was able
to turn the upstairs apartment
into part of the recovery housing so it
was four beds in one floor and five beds
upstairs so if you go
above eight residents then you have to
get a a either a sprinkler system and
then you might be able to get a variance
from the Fire Marshall but it knocks it
down to
a fire monitoring system now these fire
monitoring systems are about
$115,000 we worked with the state fir
Master's office and the coding office
and they said that we can use a
residential home monitoring system but
the deputy fight Chief and clamon was
still a little confused because he was
going
on forgive me for not knowing the terms
like the Old Law or the old bill or
whatever was in there and it took months
and months and months for us to figure
it out and yes yet again the city
definitely worked with us and so that's
one house so they're working with us and
we're just helping people and we're
going on and we're living life and then
I get the opportunity to open a female
house it is a single family house and
here's where the lengthy process started
so we had to go in front of the zoning
board for seven months because it is a
single family so at recovery housing if
you go above five residents that are not
blood related you have to get permission
from the zoning board and the city and
whoever else has their hand in this and
what happened was we were teaching each
other we were learning you know we
everything was good and we were proving
that we're a solid recovery house but it
took s months so in the meantime of that
seven months people probably died
go my girlfriend and I got multiple
calls from people are you open yet are
you open yet my daughter needs a place
to go are you open yet my mother needs a
place to go we're not open yet we're
still going in front of the zoning board
we're still going in front of the
planning board and I always want to
stress they definitely helped us along
but they didn't know they were going on
the old bill and what was in the on the
books and uh not to mention neighbors
they were thinking that a recovery house
is a rehab which it's not they were
thinking it's a boarding house which
it's not so that lengthened the process
of going in front of the zoning board
now all for the most part the zoning
board was was on board uh of letting us
and allowing us to run a recovery house
but we had to figure everything out and
I want to stress the fact that most
likely people ended up home
people ended up relapsing and probably
someone ended up dying statistically
speaking because they didn't have a
place to
go
um the main thing I want to stress is
the family environment I grew up in the
projects with my mother you know my
mother has four other children with
different fathers so I never had a solid
structured house to call home I didn't
realize what a home was until I started
getting older and that's what we provide
at a recovery house you know I could
have chose to call it hope to Freedom
know because the recovery home that I
went to was called the recovery home and
it and it helped me save my life so I
asked the owner why do you call it a
recovery home instead of sober living
and he said because we do recover that's
what we do here and when I was in that
house in Littleton I said that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to copy you
and and do
that and like we have those
uncomfortable conversations in the
recovery house why did you miss your
meeting why did you not go can we help
you with a therapist like why are you
exhibiting these behaviors why are you
late three days in a row um you know why
did you not go to work like we help
these individuals grow as a family and
that's what happens in the recovery
house it isn't just going to groups and
meetings we're like the
last the last
uh we're basically their last chance
because we teach them basic life skills
some of these guys come here and the
woman come here they don't know how to
sweep a
floor they don't know how to live life
they they get high they smoke crack they
shoot heroin they prostit prostitute
themselves and then they end up in rehab
and then they end up with us in a
recovery home and that's where the real
work
starts there's other work but when you
leave treatment now you have to go get a
job now you have to fight for your kids
again now you got to go to court you got
to get a license you got to get an ID
you got to get insurance you know you
have to do all these things you have to
go to meetings you have to go to your
12-step meetings and work your 12 steps
in order to survive another day and when
all that's not working and you come home
you have a roommate or someone else in
the house that's going to help you and
support you get through that night so
you don't use and you don't end up on
the streets again that's the difference
so once
again it took 7 months and I'm very very
grateful we have a great relationship
with the city of clamont but the thing
is it took seven months I don't know how
many people died in that seven
months um I think that's it for me thank
you so much for your time I appreciate
it thank you very
much don't go anywhere yet may be
questions are there any
I I'm acting in the unaccustomed role of
clerking uh so you said something about
early on that you operate three recovery
houses yes sir recovery homes maybe it's
the same thing and they're all in
Claremont yes all in Claremont
okay thank you very good that's it for
me for the moment all right thank you
very
Andrews thanks for having me here this
morning I am Cheryl Andrews I am the
executive director at the dismus home of
New Hampshire in
Manchester we are a level four certified
home by New Hampshire Corp that means we
are a
treatment program
along with a re-entry program we serve
specifically Justice involved women with
substance misuse and co-occurring mental
illness they can stay with us for up to
10 months is in that
timeline like Sean said we teach them
basic skills home life skills we treat
them for the trauma that
they had when they were much younger
which caused them to begin this journey
of addiction and they must be Justice
involved when they come with us come to
us that could be from directly from a
prison or a jail they could be coming
from drug court they could be uh on
parole or probation but they must have
some level of Justice involvement to be
eligible for the dismiss home program
I've been asked to talk today because we
yes we are a recovery home yes we are
looking to expand because any given day
there is approximately 500 women in the
system in New Hampshire and we want to
be able to help more of them and reduce
the rate of recidivism here in the state
so as part of our expansion this year we
recently
experienced
um a zoning board meeting that lasted
three
hours uh and it it was clear that the
city was very interested in helping us
because the the the argument back and
forth was not between us and the zba but
it was between the neighbors who were
very clear about um
it's all really great work you're doing
just don't do it in our neighborhood and
they were very clear about that I mean
they actually use those words it was
kind of shocking and for a three-hour
meeting to end up with an approval I
think that this bill would help them
help the zba and the planning
board make their decisions quicker and
clearer and disregard
the comments from the peanut
gallery on both sides that they not
appropriate for the setting or the the
program
itself I think that
um having the standard provided by the
proposed amendment helps legitimate
homes like dismiss home as well as our
cities and towns by addressing the fear
and the concerns caused by
misinformation that's pretty much what I
got thank you very much question
representative
goalie thank you madam chair and I'm not
not sure if you can answer this or not
um unfortunately the Fire Marshall can't
be here but I'll be in touch with him as
well do you know
if halfway houses fall under this
exemption or are they a totally
different entity so a halfway house is
run by um a Corrections Department we
are not a halfway house so I can't
answer that question excuse me they are
not mandated to come to us from the dism
from the corrections unit and the
Corrections Department doesn't have any
over s it of our of our organization the
representative goalie halfway houses are
specifically Exempted it's on line uh 12
12 to
thank okay anyone
else ver Schmidt thank you so uh if my
early
training uh does not betray me uh desert
me anyway so you represent dismas home
if I recall correctly dismus is the
so-called good thief yes crucified next
to Jesus yes and asked for Redemption at
the last minute and got a second chance
okay um so that that is the the
reference um and you are the owner
operator I'm the executive director of
the
organization okay and you when you say
organization how substantial is your
organization well our
current budget is about a million
dollars a year we we serve eight women
currently and we're looking to expand to
add 20 beds this year and so and this is
in manchest are you located anywhere
else not currently but our future plan
is to our founder and current board
chair would like to have a dismus home
in every county in the state of New
Hampshire uhhuh but at the moment it's
just the one home
in Manchester and you said you have
about well it varies I'm sure from 5
to8 our our our current home capacity is
eight okay thank you welcome
okay representative
Shu thank you madam chair um you stated
that during this three-hour Zoning Board
hearing there was apparently a lot of
push back from prospective neighbors uh
I assume you've been in operation since
you stated your
okay um how has acceptance been from the
neighbors since you've been in operation
so our current neighborhood at 1024th
Street actually is a very quiet Dead End
Street and we had letters of support
from our neighbors on Fourth Street
saying we've been wonderful neighbors
we've been helpful in our neighborhood
we keep the cutest house it's all pretty
so we've had great support from our
current neighbors since we've been in
operation since
2016 you're welcome okay anyone else
thank you very much you're
Hansen good morning members of the
committee my name is anina Hansen I'm
from Peterboro in the Manan
agent I'm a person in recovery from
alcoholism and once upon a time I fell
in love with another person in recovery
from alcohol and heroin
addiction Phil had sobered up several
years before in prison and when he was
released he knew he didn't stand a
chance of staying clean without a safe
and supportive place to live fortunately
he found a bed in a sober house here in
New Hampshire when he needed it it was
such a life-saving measure for him he
went on to found two sober houses of his
own giv giving scores of men a safe
place to start
again now recovery housing is not a
magical guarantee it's just the first
step in a long journey over time Phil
started a successful business he bought
his own home he met me and we built a
life together but covid happened his
mental health issues went untreated for
too long and at 5 years sober he
relapsed and died of a fentol
overdose until you've lost someone to
overdose you cannot fully understand the
absolute irredeemable futility of it it
is a pointless and preventable death
every single person who dies of overdose
on any substance is someone who with
more time and more support may have
kicked their addiction and built a
stable life this is why a safe
environment for early recovery is
crucial whenever someone substance
dependent makes the attempt to live
substance-free the risk of relapse is
highest by far in the beginning
being surrounded by like-minded people
who offer support empathy and
accountability can be the difference
between becoming a success story or a
statistic Phil used to say my guys are
like any other group of adults who
choose to live together we are a family
by choice exactly as was mentioned
earlier and we deserve the rights of a
family and certainly the rights of any
group of housemates non-clinical
recovery housing is simply a group of
men or women choosing to split expenses
by sharing a home like lots of people do
living as a single household as was
mentioned with the added benefit that
this single household creates
life-saving support for an issue we're
always talking about wanting to
mitigate anything we do to make sober
housing easier to access not harder
saves lives and those lives go on to
save more lives Phil's sober houses in
lonia are still operational and some men
have been there for years now still
craving the stability and Community they
enjoy there but most eventually reach
the point where they're ready to move on
one of Phil's former residents became a
firsttime home buyer this winter another
is running his own successful
landscaping business these guys help
their communities raise their kids pay
their taxes in anyone's book they are
recovery success stories but they didn't
get here by accident in those fraught
early days of recovery they found a soft
place to land because a guy named Phil
was willing to struggle over the hurdles
to open a Recovery House think how many
more lives can be transformed if those
hurdles are
removed we talk a lot about our state's
addiction problems one of the answers is
sober housing if we want fewer addiction
related statistics we need more recovery
housing I urge you to take the simple
yet powerful step of passing this
amendment that will make it more
straightforward to open more sober
houses and help more people start over
substance-free and stay that way thank
you thank you very much could we bother
you to have that uh written testimony
we'd like to have it for the record you
sure May would it be better if I emailed
it to you whichever is easier for you
okay I will make sure that the committee
gets it thank you any questions
representative
Schmid thank you m chair so miss Hansen
uh uh you are currently the operator of
this home in Peterboro I am not my
stepdaughter is I live in Peterboro now
my lonia the homes are in lonia my
stepdaughter took over her dad's homes
and she still runs them in lonia so and
and do are is there some kind of a state
organization that
overseas facilitates that's the next
person testifying okay yeah let me defer
then
okay but you how long have you been in
the business so to speak um my
affiliation with it is what about four
years now of just seeing it at one step
removed but seeing the
obstacles that were opposed
by difficulty around different zoning
ordinances but also seeing the huge
success when we get past those obstacles
and a sober house is allowed to
open so so you just have a home of your
own someplace else correct in in
Peterboro is it that's where I am now
yes yeah yes but the home you've been
talking about is where lonia lonia okay
thank you all right any else thank you
Bach
good morning my name is Kim Bach I'm the
executive director with the New
Hampshire Coalition of recovery
residences um thank you for the
opportunity to testify on behalf of NH
core um in support of this
amendment the reason why this whole
thing came about is because NH cor has
partnered with many organizations
throughout the state we partnered first
with the state far Marshall Sean Tumi
Tumi and um New Hampshire building
official Association President Bill
McKinny um at in the very early stages
um New Hampshire Legal Assistant was
involved and then we got together with
the St ansam Center for ethics they run
a program on the housing we need in New
Hampshire and they decided that recovery
housing ought to be a piece of that and
a discussion in that
platform so they hosted a seminar that
was directed at Town
officials and it was to listen to find
to give them some information
information but really the point of that
seminar was to listen and it was for us
to discover what are the true barriers
we had assumptions about what the
barriers were but what were the true
barriers that the towns were facing and
if we knew the true barriers if they
were because of misconceptions of what
recover recovery housing is then we
could help with education and if there
were other barriers maybe we could
address those barriers there's a report
on S Anam Center for ethics website
about what are what the findings were
from that day 100 people
attended there were 10 or 12 tables set
up and they were the people at each
table consisted of um Town officials but
also of people who run recovery houses
people who run rcos um so there was a a
good smattering of of knowledge there
were First Responders at the
tables and we had presentations and we
had um scripted questions to go through
as discussions within the tables say
transim Center for ethics compiled all
of the information at the end and put
together the report what we found
resoundingly was that the town officials
said we need guidance there's no
definition of recovery residents in the
statutes in the codes and so we're left
trying to figure this out we're left
trying to decide is a congregate housing
is it a is it a boarding home is it um
transitional housing what what is it
and they resoundingly said if we had
more guidance a clearer pathway through
the code a clearer Pathway to do our
work then it would answer a lot of
questions and it would be incredibly
helpful and that's when New Hampshire
housing stepped in to offer assistance
and they pulled together all of the
organizations that you can think of
DHHS um everyone was at the table trying
to put in input into bringing this
particular Amendment
forward and it did take a long time
because there were a lot of voices at
the table we all had opinions me
especially um in
addition NH core has participated we
will go and speak about recovery housing
at any zoning board planning board
meeting if that would be helpful and so
we've participated in many of
them what I see is Town officials who
want to do the best for their towns
they're there volun giving up their
nights with their families they're
working
hard they really do want to do the best
for their
town and they struggle and they hear an
hour and a half and and I went with
dismiss home um for their hearing and
that was not the first time I've been
involved in a hearing like that it was
the first time I felt uneasy about my
safety but it was not the first time
that I've been involved in a hearing
like that in that particular
Town
um Town officials need some guidance
it's distressing to see them try and
struggle with where should they stand
without that guidance between what they
think is right what they think they
should be doing for Recovery housing
what they think that the federal laws
say and with what the the um the public
is saying and with how emotional the
it um I have a letter for you and I can
tell you that the
voices in the room are loud and
sometimes very
aggressive um I think the town officials
would greatly benefit from this
amendment it would give them the
guidance that they need to more easily
navigate that pathway forward with
recovery housing so and I'd ask you to
recall you're hearing people that that
are more closely involved with recovery
housing than I am telling you about how
people do succeed and what happens when
houses when it takes a long time for
houses to get established that lives are
lost but remember that some people that
enter recovery housing have a 60%
greater chance of achieving remission
from addiction than people that don't
go so I thank you for your time today
questions representative shm
if I recall correctly you've been before
us before yes I have five or six years
ago may not quite that long ago but a
couple years ago right and you were
doing the same work then yes I was and
and you with New Hampshire Housing and
what is your capacity there no I am with
the New Hampshire Coalition of recovery
director all right thank you other
questions okay thank you very
much we'll take that letter please
Michelle
London good
morning um my name's Michelle Lennon and
I live in Campton New Hampshire I'm also
the executive director or president and
CEO I actually got a promotion um for
archways um it's an organization that
has four uh recovery Community
organization um centers and Family
Resource Centers U one is in conquered
on North State Street and one is in
Franklin one is in tilon and one is in
Plymouth at the whole village um I'm
also a family member of somebody who's
in recovery from um opiates um my
husband fell off a roof back in 201940
ft and he lived through it um and it's
been a long road for him a lot of
surgeries and and that's where addiction
kind of hit our family pretty hard um
I'd say I grew up thinking that bad
people did drugs I mean it was just the
message that I got in my family through
dare and and other programs so my coming
to find Addiction in my immediate family
was pretty shocking and a huge learning
curve for me um the level of stigma my
family faced um was was very sporadic I
would say um because so many people knew
like our story in our hometown like
First Responders were awesome my kids
had friends that were super supportive
and um we've just been through a lot as
a as a family um in
2015 I work also as a pastor of a church
and uh we were seeing just so much
addiction affecting so many different
families and everybody was afraid to
talk about it um because of the
treatment that you get you know and um
how you looked at kind of as a pariah in
a way sometimes what I found is I I
worked for somebody named Karen wiford
who was awesome as a home visitor doing
family support work work that's how I
got into this field um and she sent me
to so much training because I had a huge
amount to learn about what addiction was
as as disease model and how um people's
physiology do not respond to medications
thinking oh I want to be somebody
addicted to this stuff and let it ruin
my life um that's not how it was for my
family but it could have been um I was
fortunate because I got a lot of
Education pretty quickly and um was able
to be that supportive family for my
husband when he overdosed my son had
been trained and using Naran and was him
and his girlfriend like brought my
husband back so he's still alive today
he's been in recovery now for a couple
years um just went through another
surgery last October and did not take
home pay meds after a hip revision um
that's how um solid his recovery is
today um but there were times where I
could not stand living with him as the
wife um because of you know the
emotional regulation and stuff on both
of our sides because of the pain of what
I saw him go through being suicidal
crying for Jesus to take him home at
night um how painful it was but also the
stress of having to keep my household
together um my daughter graduated from
snhu last year and um my son has is a
master um doing his master's electrician
license now and and like that fell to me
and I was angry at him for that um but
it was misplaced by us because he does
have the brain disease of addiction it
was not something he chose it chose him
as a result of the medications he was
prescribed from Dartmouth um what I know
now like as um um a director basically
of of these recovery centers when people
come through our door there are families
that were like me my stinking thinking
about what addiction was um caused an
environment for my husband um that maybe
wasn't safe for his recovery because I
wanted to blame him and shame him for a
disease that he carried and it was just
wrong thinking and a lot of people think
that way um the people that we support
sometimes do not have somebody at home
that is an asset to their recovery
recovery because they just want things
fixed you know and and healing takes
time and when a guy can go into a
recovery house or a woman can go into a
recovery host and have people understand
how hard it is what they've been through
have those Supportive Services like what
Sean's talking about to help them get on
their feet it is sometimes very much
beneficial even for the family at home
the kids at home that people don't see
that get affected by this stuff um you
know I am so thankful because he my
husband actually spent time at Phoenix
house um when when there was recovery
housing in Tilton um and that month of
helping him kind of get separation from
um his misuse of substances after after
one of his surgeries um gave us peace in
our home for a month so we were ready
for him to come home when he came home
this last time as I as I mentioned when
he um came home he was fine with with no
pay meds the time before he got into
trouble with pay meds he's he's had 16
surgeries I think since the accident
um and it was done in community in the
context of community he didn't have to
go to recovery housing you know we had
the education and the support Health
First provided Vivitrol to him for a
month to get separation from his time in
the hospital and it made a huge
difference but um you know the benefit
of having a recovery home is that we
we've been moving away from an acute
care model for a long time in in
substance to support services it's so
necessary for people to have a safe
place to go where they can continue
their healing and and continue to have
support from people who get it because
so often families are hit with this
stuff and they don't get it I didn't you
know until it hit my family so I I
strongly support this bill because um it
shouldn't be up to neighbors to tell
people they can't live in their own
communities
um these houses provide that family
context when families can't do it there
are so many reasons why we need them and
I'd love to hear potentially in every
County um it is important so I
appreciate your time thank you are there
any
questions okay not seeing any excuse
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair so uh perhaps you could tell me uh
so I suppose it's not uniform or
standard but uh are these recovery
houses run by the people who live there
or do they have uh some kind of a
director or whatever does it vary what
what is your experience so my experience
is when we refer to houses we we
generally vet them and know who are
there most often they are responsible
house managers that live on site very
often they are people in recovery that
have lived at a home impr proving their
leadership skills over time one of my
Center managers actually um the Franklin
Center has been at one of our recovery
homes that we refer to for many years
and he's just outstanding like as an
individual and um he he actually manages
all of our data for our you know four
centers at this point um so and and
generally that's what happens within the
houses that we refer to um and they're
supervised all the time you know oh
thank you followup so uh the the person
uh that that manages the house are they
there throughout the day uh because I I
I would imagine it would be difficult if
there's if the person has to go away uh
for for an
regular standard employment away from
the home uh and now the home is
potentially empty or somebody there that
is I maybe not in the best of shape to
be left on their own well generally
speaking by the time somebody enters
Recovery House they've already been
through treatment you know so they are
safe you you know to be be home alone um
but it's going to vary house by house
what their parameters are for the
program mhm and maybe Kim Vach can
probably speak thankk to that better and
on your card I see it says representing
archways that's the name of the
organization that you work for or are R
are you the director of the yeah I'm the
president and CEO we have Center
managers in all four
centers the Family Resource Center
anybody can walk in and ask for help
with anything that they need help with
okay thank you good
Barry good morning Madam chair honorable
committee members my name is Jake Barry
I work for new Futures we're a
nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy and
advocacy organization I'll keep this
very brief we strongly support this
amendment for all the reasons that have
been articulated uh uh so well by by all
the folks in the back of me um the
shortage of recovery housing facilities
is one of the ma the major obstacles
that it continues to face individuals uh
uh impacted by substance use disorder
and our state as we work to overcome uh
the ongoing addiction crisis um our
communities so many of them really seem
to recognize the value of uh of recovery
houses and they they really want to be
helpful Partners in the development but
the the fact is there was a lot of
misconceptions out there or
misunderstandings about uh what recovery
housing is what it is not and that that
really infringes Upon Our communities
our cities and towns abilities uh to
support uh the increase increase access
to this invaluable resource so um this
amendment really just seeks to clarify
uh again what recovery housing is as a
it is a residential facility it is not a
Health Care Organization there is no
health care provided on premises and
therefore it really should be uh uh
subject to the same uh fire and safety
codes and zoning regulations as other
residential facilities we believe
strongly that providing this kind of
clarity again will provide important
guidance to our communities and really
help them as they want to do to achieve
um to to help the development of these
uh critical resources uh and I will
point out that again this bill uh the I
don't recall which line but it does
refer to uh houses that are either
certified by New Hampshire Corps or in
the process of being certified so again
these are are houses that are already in
the process of uh uh achieving
all of these established uh health and
safety codes as defined by core and the
their National Affiliates so um with
that I'm happy to take any questions so
consideration
questions seeing none thank you very
much I do have written testimonial pass
is there uh anyone else who wishes to
testify on this
amendment all right seeing none I will
close the public
hearing
now